اشارت صحيفه الوول ستريت جورنال الى انه
لا نهايه في الافق لحرب اسرائيل ضد حركه
حماس ويقول خبراء ان هدف اسرائيل الاساسي
من الحرب سيكون من الصعب تحقيقه قريبا حتى
لو استولت القوات الاسرائيليه على كامل
مساحه غزه ويقول عثر فريدمان الباحث في
دراسات الحرب تمتعت حماس بدرجه عاليه من
الاستقلال لمده 20 عاما لتطوير قدراتها
واعدت نفسها للحرب وهي تعلم بالضبط اين
سيحدث القتال وكل ذلك يجعل هدف تدمير حماس
اكثر صعوبه من الناحيه العسكريه قالت
صحيفه الواشنطن بوست ان الاسر في غزه
تكافح من اجل تء المجاعه وتنقل عن بعض
السكان قولهم انه من الممكن رؤيه الناس
يموتون من الجوع في الشوارع اذا استمر
الوضع الحالي ويقول المتحدث باسم برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي ستيف تارلا ان حجم وسرعه
هذه الازمه لم يسبق لهما مثيل في العصر
الحديث رات صحيفتها ارت في افتتاحيتها ان
على اسرائيل انلا تعيد الاستيطان الى قطاع
غزه قائله ان الجناح العنصريه في الحكومه
والكنيست يعرض وجود اسرائيل للخطر ويحولها
الى دوله منبوذه في العالم وهذا دليل على
الحاجه الملحه لاجراء انتخابات عامه في
اسرع وقت ممكن واسقاط حكومه نتنياهو
الكارثيه نشرت صحيفه جور سلم بوست
الاسرائيليه نتائج استطلاع للراي اظهر ان
حزبا جديدا من جنود الاحتياط يحدث هزه في
السياسه الاسرائيليه وكشف الاستطلاع ان
هذا الحزب الجديد الذي يراسه عدد من
المرشحين من ذوي الخلفيه العسكريه سيحظى
بدعم قوي وقد يحصل على عشره مقاعد في
الانتخابات المقبله نشرت مجله نيوز ويك
مقالا بقلم دانييل ديميتريس قال فيه ان
الصراعات في غزه واليمن مرتبطه ببعضها ولا
تصدق اداره بايدن بهذا الخصوص وفق قوله
مضيفا ان الحوثيين كان لديهم موقف منذ
اكتوبر بان الهجمات في البحر الاحمر
ستستمر طالما استمرت الحرب في غزه والامر
ذاته ينطبق على الهجمات ضد القواعد
الامريكيه في العراق وسوريا لكن اداره
بايدن تتجاهل هذه الحقيقه باعتبارها خطرا
عليها نشرت الجارديان مقالا لكريس ماك
جريل قال فيه ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
اظهر انه مستعد لدفع ثمن سياسي مقابل دعمه
لاسرائيل وسيكون من المبالغه بالتالي ويل
على خوض بايدن مواجهه ضد تعنه نتنياهو مما
يؤكد لبقيه العالم اكثر من اي وقت مضى ان
الولايات المتحده اختارت الوقوف الى جانب
القمع انتقدت افتتاحيه صحيفه تشاينا ديلي
الصينيه استخدام الولايات المتحده حقوق
الانسان كسلاح وقالت ان صمت بعض الدول
المتقدمه على انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
المستمره في قطاع غزه يظهر بجلاء المعايير
المزدوجه التي تتبعها وتضيف ان واشنطن تلج
لتسييس حقوق الانسان في بعض الحالات
كوسيله للضغط على الحكومات الاجنبيه بل
وحتى الاطاحه بها